ils ont pris la fuite par dizaines de
milliers des combattants des hommes des
femmes et des enfants
ils ont suivi de gré ou de force le
groupe armé état islamique jusque dans
ses derniers retranchements à ben arous
en syrie là où les forces de la
coalition cherche à asséner un coup
final groupes jihadistes depuis le début
décembre plus de cinquante mille
personnes se sont ainsi rendus aux
forces arabo kurde selon l'observatoire
syrien des droits de l'homme et peur
parmi eux émis une canadienne originaire
de l'alberta et ses deux jeunes garçons
omar 7 ans et daoud cinq ans c'est son
mari qui lui a ordonné de venir le
rejoindre en syrie avec les enfants dit
elle
ça a été très dur pour moi de le faire
mais vous savez ce que c'est vous aimez
votre mari vous savez qu'il ne veut que
votre bien parce que vous avez des
enfants
je le connaissais depuis si longtemps
depuis dix ans déjà
je lui faisais confiance à l'aise mais
il était dans un endroit très dangereux
à 46 ans kimberly probablement la
doyenne des épouses d'origine étrangère
de leuilly elle aussi raconte avoir été
poussé trompée par son mari dit elle
un kenyan rencontrées en ligne à qui
elle reproche d'avoir profité de sa
maladie et de ce qu'elle qualifie de
dépression j'ai été culpabilisés on m'a
poussé et je n'aurais pas dû garder tout
ça pour moi je regrette de ne pas avoir
parlé avec ma famille mais mon mari me
disait qu'il n'était pas musulman que
leurs opinions ne comptait pas mais ce
n'est pas vrai quand elles ont quitté le
canada les crimes du groupe armé
islamique était déjà largement documenté
des journalistes décapiter un pilote
jordanien brûlis beef la vente l
esclavage sexuel de famille zidi
arrachés à leur village pourtant il
affirme ne pas avoir su la véritable
nature de
i de ne pas s'être informé avant de
prendre le chemin de pays en guerre
kimberley emi qui se sont convertis à
l'islam à l'âge adulte disent avoir été
choqué de ce qu'ils ont découvert assez
rapidement atteint 4,6 l'enfer existe
sur terre je les trouvais des
bombardements incessants des menaces des
gens à qui je ne faisais pas confiance
tout autour de moi me retourner sans
arrêt la peur toute la journée tous les
jours
kimberley dit avoir un moment tenté de
s'enfuir ce qui lui a valu d'être
dénoncé par celui qui était désormais
son ex mari est emprisonné par le i en
prison elle a été battue et violée
je veux oublier je veux oublier beaucoup
de choses
ses geôliers lui ont permis de quitter
après qu'elle ait accepté de signer son
propre arrêt de mort si elle cherchait à
s'enfuir de nouveau dit elle doré une
jeune femme originaire de toronto a
quant elle une expérience tout en
contrastes
à son arrivée à vaka et elle a été
agréablement surprise
tout le monde croit que tu arrives en
syrie et suzie dans les tentes dans les
montagnes sans électricité ni eau
courante
les gens se disent que c'est comme ça le
djihad vous savez meilleur accueil vous
avez votre propre maison il y as
d'électricité 24 heures sur 24 vous
vivez dans une belle maison vous mangez
vos points gosse et vous mangez des
barthes ou x c'est comme si vous n'étiez
jamais parties qui ne veulent afte la
jeune mère croit que comme elle beaucoup
de femmes étrangères ont rejoindre
l'état islamique simplement pour vivre
selon la charia et certains de ses
avantages comme l'interdiction de
contracter un prêt avec intérêts elles
se disent peut-être je peux aller à un
autre endroit où je vais vivre dans une
maison qui sera à moi où je n'ai rien à
payer
je n'ai pas emprunté pour faire ci ou ça
je peux vivre librement ses maisons
offertes aux djihadistes et à leur
famille gratuitement le groupe armé état
islamique ne les avaient pas construite
elle appartenait plutôt à des résidents
draka qui ont pris la fuite ou pire qui
ont été assassinés par le lit après la
prise de ras cash
elle arrive difficilement faire des
reproches à neuilly ou a exprimé des
regrets pour le choix qu'elle a fait
nasser al qassimi 15 c'est une question
difficile
si je n'étais pas venu je n'aurai pas
mes enfants ne serait ce que pour ça au
moins ils ont passé du temps avec leur
père nous étions en famille
si j'étais resté comme ça dans ma petite
bulle à la maison avec mes enfants et
femmes
nous avons eu du bon temps vraiment j'ai
rencontré des gens bien beau coup de
sort très bien malgré ce qu'elle décrit
comme une vie familiale satisfaisante
doré s'est divorcé de son mari une femme
célibataire ne pouvant presque rien
faire dans le canif à elle s'est
retrouvée avec un gardien titre i par
l'eau y est mis aussi s'est vite
retrouvée seule en syrie il n'y a plus
de deux ans son mari canadien est mort
au combat près de man bij je ne voulais
vraiment pas me marier j'étais tout à
fait contre j'ai essayé longtemps de
m'en sortir seul avec les enfants
pendant presque deux ans mais vers la
fin je n'en pouvais plus je sentais que
j'étais dans un monde d'hommes
je ne connaissais pas la langue arabe je
ne pouvais pas aller chercher de l'eau
sans voiture si les enfants tombés
malades
je ne savais plus quoi faire je ne
pouvais pas aller à l'hôpital
j'ai senti que je devais me marier amy
est aujourd'hui enceinte de ce deuxième
mari un bosniaque le camp de and roll
abrite maintenant plus de 40000
personnes dont 2000 familles étrangères
selon les gestionnaires du cas des
familles que les autorités du kurdistan
cette zone semi autonome au nord de la
syrie voudrait voir rentrer chez elles
le plus rapidement possible les
canadiennes que nous avons rencontrés
sont d'accord tout souhaitent rentrer au
canada au plus vite
si vous croyez que j'ai fait quelque
chose de mal
si vous voulez m'accuser de quelque
chose amenez moi en justice je n'ai rien
fait alors et valérie dréville rome
mais si vous y tenez à ce point offrez
mois un procès équitable fairtrade
je ne veux plus jamais revenir dans ce
coin du monde jamais rémunéré
je suis vraiment canadienne ma façon de
penser et canadiennes je ne crois pas en
la violence je vois des armes et j'ai
peur je n'en veux pas qu'ils me lydie
qu'elle comprend les réserves qu'ont les
canadiens à accepter qu'elle et les
autres canadiens qui se sont joints à
lui puisse revenir au pays à aix tata a
et b je m'attends à être tenu pour
responsable de tout ce que j'ai fait de
mal je n'ai jamais voulu blesser qui que
ce soit je n'ai aucun intérêt pour la
violence et je ne veux de mal à personne
mais je veux vivre une vie aussi normale
que possible et être avec ma famille et
me aussi espère pouvoir rentrer auprès
de sa famille ses enfants dit elle
tous les deux nés au canada ne devrait
pas être puni pour ce que leurs parents
ont choisi de faire je veux leur offrir
l'enfant ce que j'ai eus je ne veux pas
de cette vie pour eux je veux pouvoir
leur donner les mêmes expériences que
j'ai eu
j'ai voyagé je suis allé dans des parcs
d'amusement
j'ai fréquenté des écoles formidable je
ne crois pas qu'il mérite ça et non un
soc mois avec 1000 sont si jeunes
peut-être ne se souviendront-ils de rien
de tous
à côté
[Musique]